an earthquake is measured with an
amplitude 1,000 times as large as the
smallest possible measurable amplitude
which is denoted by a with the subscript
0 or a sub 0 what is the magnitude of
this earthquake using the Richter scale
to the nearest tenth so when Charles
Richter set up the Richter scale he
defined the Richter scale value of the
smallest Magnus must measurable
earthquake at at zero so if the
amplitude is a sub zero the Richter
scale value so this is amplitude
amplitude and this is the Richter scale
Richter scale is going to be zero and
that for anything larger than that you
are essentially going to take the log of
the multiple of this smallest value so
if you want to find the Richter scale so
let's take the example in this in this
question right over here if we have an
earthquake let's call that Q its
amplitude is Q and it is 1,000 times as
strong as the smallest measurable
amplitude so it's 1,000 times a sub-zero
the way that you the way that you would
find the Richter scale value for this
earthquake right over here you would say
that the Richter scale value is equal to
the logarithm base 10 base 10 of the
amplitude of your quake divided by the
amplitude of the smallest the smallest
possible quake and this is obviously
going to be this is going to be equal to
in our case log base 10 of Q is 1,000
times that smallest 1000 times that
smallest measurable quake and then we
divide that time by a Sub Zero and
what's neat here is that these two
characters cancel out so it becomes log
base 10 of a thousand log base 10 of
1000 which is asking us what is the
power I have to raise 10 to to get to a
thousand well I raise 10 to the third
power 10 times 10 times 10 is a thousand
so this is going to be equal to three so
the Richter value the Richter scale
value to the nearest tenth
and actually this is with complete
precision if we assume that this has all
of the information in it the Richter
scale value to the nearest tenth is
going to be 3.0 and so one way to think
about it is if you see a Richter scale
value of 3.0 you immediately know that
this is 10 to the third and that's where
the 3 comes in 10 to the third times as
strong as the weakest measurable
earthquake or a thousand times as strong
as the weakest measurable earthquake if
you saw a Richter scale value of 2 that
is 10 to the 2nd power as strong as the
weakest possible or a hundred times as
strong if you see your Richter scale a 4
that's 10 to the 4th times strong or
10,000 times as strong so I think you
get the picture
but the big realization here is that
there's actually a big difference you
might say hey you know I saw something
there was an earthquake on the Richter
scale that was a 5 let's say you have
something 1 earthquake on the Richter
scale that is a 5.0 and then you have
another earthquake on the Richter scale
that is a 7.0 this might not seem that
big of a difference but this is 10 to
the 5th times as strong as a weakest
earthquake this is 10 to the 7th times
as strong as the weakest earthquake so
this is a million this is 10 million
times as strong this this right over
here is a hundred thousand times as
strong as the weakest earthquake so the
difference between a 5 and a 7 is
actually a factor of 100 you have 2
powers of two years so 7.0 is a hundred
times as strong as a 5.0 a 9.0 a 9.0
would be a hundred times as strong as a
7.0 which is already a devastating
earthquake and it would be 10,000 times
as strong as a 5.0 which is actually a
pretty sizable or quick already so you
could imagine when you hear about these
9.0 earthquakes that happen in Chile and
in Japan that is 10,000 times as strong
as a 5.0 earthquake which is still a
nice earthquake I mean that's an
earthquake that will shake you in your
seat pretty pretty pretty well